welcome back so we're going through this
roadmap 2030 document on how control
theory is going to be Central in
addressing some of the largest societal
scale challenges in the next coming
decades
and in this video I'm going to zoom in
specifically on the topic of Education
which is a real passion of mine very
near and dear to my heart and so that's
chapter six of this roadmap that's what
I'm going to talk about today
uh this is a quote the success of a
community depends on the education of
its members okay this is a quote I made
up just now but I think it's absolutely
true and this is not just true of the
control Community if you have a
community this community will Thrive or
fall based on how well educated its
members are and so this is a huge
uh kind of obligation and responsibility
of us especially those of us who are
more senior in the community to make
sure that we're doing a good job of
conveying our knowledge educating the
Next Generation showing them the
problems that are important the pitfalls
that we've made so that they can learn
from them uh you know kind of getting
them off on the right foot as early as
possible so that they have the tools
they need to really take these
Technologies in control theory and go
and solve the next generation of
problems with them okay again something
I'm super passionate about it's why I
get up in the morning it is why I'm here
today uh with you and it's honestly it's
one of the big purposes of this roadmap
document it's an educational effort we
want to get people focused on the really
hard problems we want to come together
we want to get young people excited
about the opportunity for control theory
to help
good
uh and there's a lot of recommendations
so in this document there are some
recommendations like things we should do
are you know actually really address and
go back to the the drawing board should
we be starting with frequency domain or
time domain that's a question that
doesn't often get asked I know that
there are a few places in the world uh
you know that start off in the time
domain my book is one of them I know
Caltech you know I learned where I
learned control theory we started in the
time domain most of the rest of the
world uh you know starts off in this
frequency domain dominated world that's
that's very historical and it's not
clear that that's how things should be
forever I'm not saying we should always
start to you know with systems of
differential equations but at least we
should be having these discussions
what's the good starting ground what is
the broadest way we can introduce
control theory to the world this is
something that's usually introduced in a
fairly Advanced mathematical concept
uh what are ways that we can introduce
control theory earlier to people okay so
I I again I work in the intersection of
control theory and machine learning and
data science and there are these
discussions in every engineering
department I visited in the last few
years how do we make it so that there is
an introduction to data science or an
introduction to machine learning class
for first-year undergraduates in college
I would ask the same question for
control theory
control theory is one of the most
Central and important uh hinge pin ideas
in all of engineering it ties together
so many different fields of engineering
they all come together in this systems
and control perspective so how do we
integrate this into the first year
curriculum for undergraduates how do we
get high school students excited about
these and that's one of the things that
this road map for societal scale
challenges is trying to address is a lot
of young people really do get motivated
by the good that they can do and by
getting people focused on challenges
that control theory can can actually
help address at a high level not even
thinking about the mathematics
necessarily that's a pretty smart way of
getting people engaged so really
important how do we get people engaged
earlier more broadly sometimes that
means changing the title of courses
dusting off your you know uh your your
control theory class and maybe thinking
about what is a modern title or a modern
take on that topic that can get broader
engagement
you know more diverse audiences younger
audiences very important for our
community to live and Thrive is to
educate everybody
another kind of key recommendation and
point in this chapter is that we need to
be focusing more on computational
methods right so much of control theory
in the olden days was pencil and paper
by hand when in reality this is very
much a living and computational
field right so when I compute a Bodhi
plot or an iquest plot I'm using
software and really making sure that we
are getting our students up to speed
with the modern computational approaches
to these things is critical and I've
just shown one example here I don't want
to play favorites there are lots of good
control theory packages and lots of good
languages there's Matlab there's python
you can do this you know to some extent
in in most languages I do think that the
fact that python control is free and
open source you can download this
anywhere in the world and get started
immediately is a pretty amazing resource
and so you know when I think
computational I think open source and
open because again that's going to get
the broadest engagement and that's a
pretty major transition right like when
I teach control theory today I'm much
more likely to do it in Matlab because
that's where all of my Historical Notes
and you know kind of lectures are
prepared in but again I think we owe it
to ourselves to think about what are the
Technologies of the future is if open
source is something we as a community
believe in and believe is going to be
useful in an educational
platform then we really need to start
embracing that and and moving towards
that and kind of putting our time
towards towards that effort and I think
this is a very commendable goal where
these tools have actually been really
largely ported over to python for free
uh again another recommendation is if
you want to get students excited about
control theory show them how it
interfaces with machine learning which
is one of the greatest technological
advances of our of Our Generation if not
of all time right like we are starting
to to see that perhaps machine learning
is going to be up there with electricity
and the electric light in terms of broad
impact on society you know like up there
with the internet and cell phones and so
really you know we would be doing a
disservice to ourselves and our students
if we don't show them this Rich history
and future at the intersection of
machine learning and control theory okay
I of course have you know dozens of
videos on this this is what I research
in my my lab researches is this
intersection but you know we as a
community really need to be embracing
this and and I think control theory for
a number of reasons was a little bit on
the cautious or or hesitant side early
on to adopt these methods which I think
is reasonable to be cautious and and
prudent because control theory relies on
certifiable and you know guaranteed
performance and robustness and stability
and things like that but increasingly
you know we can't just ignore this huge
emerging field of machine learning we
need to be embracing this we need to
fold it into our curriculum we need to
train our young people to know when it
can be trusted how it can be used and
what the challenges are for the future
okay and I think we're actually doing a
pretty good job of that now now which
I'm excited I just went to you know the
ACC American Controls conference and
this was on everybody's mind and that
kind of now it's cautious optimism of
how we're actually going to use these
tools to advance the field so I think
that's pretty cool
another piece of this and recommendation
from this chapter is maybe these large
college courses is not the best way to
teach young people control theory maybe
we want a more modular approach maybe we
want you know more focused and tailored
modular approaches to to learning this
is something again I'm super passionate
about I've been doing for years Brian
Douglas from uh Matt from YouTube's
control lectures has also been doing
this even longer in control theory so
these are just two examples of many uh
researchers and Educators who were
putting modular online control theory
curriculum out there for free on the
internet so students can kind of pick
and choose and build their knowledge in
a much much more flexible way and kind
of my uh
rationale for putting together my
controlled boot camp which has been
pretty
um widely used across the world to my
you know much to my
um
you know very very much my pleasure to
see that being used by people
um I just wanted my students to get a
really rapid crash course into control
theory that didn't take them 30 hours I
wanted you know a five or ten hour
really really high level short focused
introduction and it turns out people
across the world want that too so again
for all of us on both sides of this on
the Educators and the senior control
theory side and the young people who
want to be learning control theory I
think we can be doing you know a better
job of making our work interesting and
getting it out there in this modular
flexible really user-friendly way
all of these videos for example you know
I've had code now in Matlab and python
that was something you know it took a
lot of time and a lot of effort but I've
noticed when I talk to students it
really pays off because it allows them
to learn the way that is best for them
you know similarly all of those videos
and control theory are following a
couple of chapters in this book by
myself and Nathan Kutz this is not just
a Shameless plug for my book I want to
point out all of the sections every
single section in this book has a short
video associated with it with codes in
Matlab and Python and that's the kind of
thing we're going to need in the future
if we really want our our education to
hit everybody in the world so that
everybody knows how important control
theory is we need this to you know
integrate computational methods
integrate modern advances in machine
learning be modular and flexible have
open source code to go with everything
so that people can play with it
themselves and change things and learn
in that way okay I hope you can tell
this is something I love this is truly
one of my passions and one of the things
that I feel driven and called to do is
to educate people especially in control
theory and I know my amazing colleagues
you know many of them co-authors on this
roadmap document have so much knowledge
to impart to the Young Generation I
really want to see this
um you know be fruitful and again our
success depends on the education of our
of our you know our new members
um one last parting thought in those
veins
I don't think I've said this enough but
all of my videos in my control boot camp
are really inspired by the control
education I received
um when I was in school most of this was
you know from Richard Murray at Caltech
and Clancy rally at Princeton and Clancy
learned a lot of controls from from
Richard Murray so you know I really also
want to point out that this is a
multi-generational affair like we learn
from great teachers and then we become
teachers to other people and pass that
along so so two things uh thanks to to
Richard and Clancy and also you know
let's let's pass this forward and
actually make sure we're educating the
Next Generation okay thank you